gentlemen the Bellagio vault its
safeguards every time that comes through
each of the three casinos above it and
we're gonna get up and Robin
smash-and-grab job huh slightly more
complicated than that
actually I think that's a perfect way to
describe it I'm gonna get smashed and
grab a bunch of money anyway first up we
have to figure out a way to get by all
the armed security guards and the only
way I can think to distract them is to
have one of us dress up like a hot chick
- I'm gonna pick you for that job not
just because of your gentle feminine
facial features but also you kind of
seem like a guy that would like dressing
up like a woman
yeah great that was easy staples button
boom easy button cuz staples you
remember the ads after that there's a
vocal confirmation system that'll only
open the Security Center doors with a
specific voice which we can't fake
unless we get sober which we won't get
then I'm thinking we dig a smoke break
time being seen by the cameras good boy
it is definitely not legal next we get
the elevator shaft which is rigged with
motion detectors meaning if we were to
manually override the lift the shafts
exit would lock down automatically we'd
be trying hold on this is my favorite
part this is 3d cool anyways once we get
down the shaft we just have to get
through that you just vault doors and
three jacked up ninjas with Uzis and
we're good to go
any questions well say we do all that
we're just supposed to walk out of there
with a hundred and fifty million dollars
in cash on us without getting stopped
hmm I did not think of that and we're
gonna have to be high as balls that
we're gonna figure it out alright
everyone take some of that ecstasy candy
I gave you it's gonna be a long night
okay